Okay, so to begin our conversation this
evening, insha'Allah, we'll start with
Dr. Zakir Naik. So, Dr. Zakir Naik, to
set the scene and to give some context
to this topic, what reform would you
want in the way of the ummah
in the modern world today when it comes
to following the sunnah?
Alhamdulillah. As-salatu was-salam ala
Rasulillah wa ala alihi wa sahbihi
ajma'in. Amma ba'd. A'udhu billahi min
ash-shaytani rajim. Bismillahir Rahmanir
Rahim. Rabbi shrahli sadri wa yassirli
amri wahlul uqdatan min lisani yafqahu
qawli. I welcome all of you with the
Islamic greetings Assalamualaikum
warahmatullahi wabarakatuh.
May peace, mercy, and blessings of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala be on all of you.
Regarding what reform I would want for
the present ummah in today's time, of
course, we had a 2-day conference and
all what the speakers said is relevant
to it.
But, I would like to focus on one point
that's very important reform.
Of course, we cannot reform the sunnah.
The sunnah is the same. We have to go
back to the original sunnah.
But, reforming the present ummah.
Today,
even if we agree that we'll not go on
that point where Muslims are not
following sunnah. I would like to go to
that part of the ummah where Muslims are
following sunnah.
What reform I like?
First, number one, the Muslim should be
aware that amongst the sunnah, which is
the most important sunnah? He should
first try to do the most important
sunnah.
If he cannot do,
then the second best. Or if he wants to
do five sunnahs in any particular act,
I'll come to it. He should try and do
the best.
For example, the first question Allah
will ask you on the day of judgment is
about your deeds and about your salah.
The most important sunnah amongst all
the sunnah after the farz,
which is the most important sunnah?
The most important sunnah after the farz
is
is which? Anyone tell me.
Which is the most important sunnah?
Number one sunnah after doing all your
minimum farz
that you have to do,
the most important Sunnah according to
me
is the Qiyam al-Layl.
The most important indeed is salah.
After you complete your five time salah,
the most important Sunnah salah
is Qiyam al-Layl. If you want to offer
any Sunnah
in salah, you should first try and offer
Qiyam al-Layl.
And the best time to offer in the last
third
of the night. If you cannot, then you
offer it in the early part after your
Isha salah.
The most important according to me and
according to the Hadith
is
Qiyam al-Layl.
If it's coupled with Tahajjud salah, you
get up in the
last one third of the night and pray
your salah. It was part of the for the
prophet,
not for the Ummah.
For us, it's Mustahab.
And for a Da'ee,
it is more important.
So, if a Muslim comes and tells me, "I
want to offer Sunnah salah.
I will offer the two rak'at after wudu."
Is it a Sunnah? Yes.
We know the Hadith of Muhammad
Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam talking about
Bilal, may Allah be pleased with him. I
don't want to go into the detail. It is
a Sunnah. But if someone says, "I want
to offer the Sunnah." It's good. I'm not
against it. But if you're going to offer
only one Sunnah salah, which is the most
important?
Qiyam al-Layl.
Along with Tahajjud.
Okay, I cannot offer Tahajjud.
I cannot wake up in the middle. Okay.
Offer the witr
after Isha. The next important Sunnah
is the Sunnah before the Fajr salah, two
rak'at. Our beloved prophet said, "The
two rak'at Sunnah before the Fajr is
more valuable than the world and the
wealth in it."
Imagine.
So, which is more important? The two
rak'at after wudu or two rak'at before
the Fajr salah? So, if you know the
importance of the Sunnah salah, you
first try and do the most important
Sunnah. And by any way you cannot do,
then try and do the second best. Then
the third best. So in salah the most
important is Qiyam al-Layl. Tahajud is
the best.
Next important sunnah
is the two rak'ah
before the Fajr salah. Then
is the sunnah mu'akkadah
which the two rak'ah sunnah before Fajr
is included. Then the two plus two
before the Dhuhr salah, two after the
salah, two after the Maghrib salah, and
two after the Isha salah.
So first you follow the highly
recommended sunnah.
Then the recommended sunnah, then the
sunnah.
Sunnah can be divided into three
broad types if you want. Highly
recommended,
and only sunnah.
Then which is the recommended sunnah?
The prophet said
of
Salat al-Duha. I won't go into the
details. I'm Ishaq.
So next if you want to offer after
offering
the sunnah mu'akkadah which are 12
rak'ah in a day, Salat al-Duha.
These are all highly recommended sunnah.
Which is the next recommended sunnah?
There are many recommended sunnah. I'll
just pick up one which has come to my
mind. It is Tahiyatul Masjid.
The prophet in the Jumu'ah salah, there
is no sunnah before Jumu'ah salah. While
giving khutbah he saw a sahabah coming
and sitting. He stopped his khutbah and
asked him, "Did you offer your two
rak'ah Tahiyatul Masjid?" He said, "No."
He said, "Stand up and offer."
It's a recommended sunnah.
Not as highly recommended as Qiyam
al-Layl or the two rak'ah before Fajr.
Then the other sunnah
as sunnah ghair mu'akkadah in which the
prophet missed without any reason.
So if you want to offer salah, go in
order. If you cannot do for certain
reason, go to next. Offering two rak'ah
after wudu is good. I'm not against it.
But more important are the more
important sunnah and then you can go to
that.
So if you know the order of the sunnah
which is more important
you will get more sawab
and more chances of entering jannah and
more chances of washing away your sins.
Then you can offer the other salah
whether you're leaving your house,
entering the house and you do
two rak'ah.
All these are sunnah but more important
the Muslim knows which is more
important. He tries and does the most
important then the second then the
third. Let me give you one more example.
My staff in Malaysia
he does alhamdulillah religiously
the third important pillar of Islam. He
does his fasting on Monday and Thursday
religiously, masha Allah. Very good.
Alhamdulillah.
But then I find that he's not doing the
other more important fasting.
Fasting is a fard for every Muslim in
the month of Ramadan. Besides Ramadan is
not a fard.
But someone is fasting on Monday,
Thursday very good.
But then he's not offering
the fasting
of the
first nine days of Dhul Hijjah. Maybe
only one but not the first eight days.
So which is the most important fasting
after the fast of Ramadan?
It is the fasting on Arafah.
I won't go into the references it will
take time. Our prophet said if you fast
on the day of Arafah two years sins will
be forgiven.
Which is the second most important
sunnah fast?
It is fasting on Ashura.
The 10th of Muharram.
Arafah is the 9th of Dhul Hijjah
then is the
10th of Muharram. The prophet said if
you fast in Ashura
your one year sin will be forgiven.
If you add up both technically one year
is not overlapping. It's not it's three
years.
One year sin of the last year
and the
next year.
When you come
to Muharram the year changes.
And the hadith says one year sin so if
you add up
both together it is three years sin
are forgiven. So the second most
important is fasting on the 10th day
of Muharram, Ashura.
Then which is important? Then the first
eight days
of Dhul-Hijjah. The prophet said, "Any
deed done
in these 10 days of Dhul-Hijjah,
it is better than any other deeds."
Sahaba asked him, "Even better than
jihad?" He said, "Yes, even better than
jihad unless you go and you die in the
battlefield and give up all your wealth.
That is the only deed better."
So, amongst the good deed, if you fast
on the first eight days, ninth day is
already covered by me on the day of
Arafah. It is more important THAN THE
OTHER FASTING. SO, if you know the
order,
if you want to fast,
fast those which are more important.
Then you have
the Ayyam-ul-Bid.
The three white days, 13th, 14th, and
15th of every
month.
Then you have the days of Shawwal, six
days.
No difference of opinion which is
Shawwal is
Some scholars say more better than
Ayyam-ul-Bid, but the first three order
there's no difference of opinion.
Then you can come on Monday and
Thursday. And
today,
while meet and greet,
the question came on fasting and asked
him, "Which is the most important sunnah
fasting?" He said, "Monday, Thursday."
It's good. I'm not against fasting. But
if you're not keeping the one-day fast
which will
forgive you a two-years sins, a one-day
fast which will forgive you a one-year
sins,
so if you know your priorities of the
sunnah, you will get more thawab.
Any sunnah, you will get thawab,
but
you should know
which is more important. So, of course,
the salah is more important, then comes
fasting. In fasting, which fasting is
more important? People come and tell me,
"I like sweet dish, it's sunnah."
You think sweet dish is sunnah? Of
course, the prophet loved sweet dishes,
but the brother is not saying bismillah
before eating food.
Saying bismillah before eating food is a
more priority of Sunnah than eating
sweet dishes.
So, I would request the ummah today,
especially in the modern era, who's
following the Sunnah, do a little bit
research
which of the Sunnah is more important
and try and do the more important Sunnah
if it's impossible
to do all the Sunnah. And when I told
the brother,
"The brother, do you know that the
prophet never fasted every Monday and
Thursday?" He got the shock of his life.
It's a Sunnah to fast on Monday and
Thursday, but the prophet never fasted
every Monday and every Thursday.
But the brother is doing it.
It's good, you can do it.
Alhamdulillah, but you do the more
important
Sunnah, so in less Sunnah you get more
reward.
So, if we do a little research that
which Sunnah is more highly recommended,
which is recommended, which is
only a Sunnah, inshallah, the chances
that you go to Jannah is higher.
Alhamdulillah, shukran. Masha Allah,
barak Allah fikum. One big takeaway from
that is prioritization. We only have so
much time in a day and try to pick, as
you said, uh Dr. Zakir Naik, the ones
which have
more priority and more reward with less
effort, right? That's being efficient
and productive about it. Masha Allah.
And to do that, of course, it requires
some knowledge. It requires for us to
know what the priorities are. So, what
this is leading towards when it comes to
this conversation is that when we talk
about reform, before we speak about
reform of the ummah, it starts with the
reforming ourselves first.